>> Gayathri Rajan: Hello everyone.
Welcome and thank you for coming to, to meet
Leymah Gbowee.
Before she comes on stage we have, I will,
I'll be showing you a video.
[sound of helicopter]
[low music]
>>Leymah Gbowee: Money, greed, ethnicity,
absolute power.
There is nothing that should make people do
what they did to the children of Liberia.
[music/singing in African language starts]
>>Leymah Gbowee: The warlords would give these
boys guns and send them off.
>>female #1: They'd just do anything because
they had guns.
>>Leymah Gbowee: You go to bed saying, "God,
please what do we do?"
The women of Liberia want peace.
Now.
I had a dream.
And it was like a crazy dream.
We decided to protest.
[electronic music with vocals] We wore the
white, saying to people we were out for peace.
Thousands of women, Muslim and Christian,
were coming together from different walks
of life.
These women had seen the worst, but they still
had that vibrance for life.
>>female #2: And we said, well, if I should
get killed, just remember me that I was fighting
for peace.
[gunshot]
[drums]
>>Leymah Gbowee: We stepped out first and
did the unimaginable.
To send out a signal to the world that we
the Liberian women, we are tired of the killing
of our people.
We can do it again if we want to.
[music/singing ends]
>> Gayathri Rajan: That's a quick introduction.
This is just a tease.
I would encourage everyone to go see the movie,
Pray the Devil Back to Hell.
It's an award-winning documentary about, about
this mission and the central figure is Leymah.
So just a few words on Leymah.
She was born in Liberia and was only 17 when
the Second Liberian Civil War erupted.
This was a very brutal conflict and it tore
apart her life and claimed the lives of many
of her family and friends.
And the years of fighting had destroyed her
country, remember, this was the second civil
war, there was a first one before that, and
her hopes and dreams.
As a young mother trapped in a nightmare of
domestic abuse, she found the courage to turn
her bitterness into action, realizing that
it is women who suffer most during conflict
and that the power of women working together
can create an unstoppable force.
Working as a social worker and a trauma counselor
during the war, she organized the Women of
Liberia Mass Action for Peace, which was a
multi-cultural and a multi-religious group,
it included Christians as well as Muslims
in Liberia, who prayed for peace, held nonviolent
protests, including a sex strike [laughing],
which resulted in a promise from President
Charles Taylor to attend peace talks in Ghana.
This group was critical in bringing an end
to the civil war in 2003 and the election
of Ellen Johnson-Sirleaf in Liberia, she is
the first African female president.
In 2007 Leymah was awarded the Blue Ribbon
for Peace from the John F. Kennedy School
of Government at Harvard and she's also co-founder
and Executive Director of Women Peace and
Security Network in Africa, this is an organization
dedicated to training women, advocating for
peace and security in African governance.
If all this was not enough, she's also the
author of Mighty Be Our Powers.
The book is, is for sale for $10 outside and
I would recommend, I would encourage you if
you are interested in reading more about her,
her history, her personal history as well
as her political actions to have it signed
personally by Leymah herself.
And she's also, as, as we just saw, a central
figure in, in the movie.
So it brings us all great joy and it's a special
privilege to have someone of her stature and,
and her, her impact come to talk to us.
Welcome Leymah.
[applause]
>>Megan Smith: Ok.
Can you guys hear us?
Hello.
Thank you, Gayathri.
Leymah, it's amazing to have you here.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Well, it's amazing to be
here, I'm just overwhelmed.
I'm not one to get blown away by America and
the sight of things, but Google has just really
blown me out of my whatever.
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: We hope we can be helpful.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Well it is.
>>Megan Smith: Good.
You've done extraordinary things.
There's a, I mean the people who've written,
not only your book is incredible, Mighty Be
Our Powers, but just looking at some of the
comments in the back and the one I just wanted
to call out Archbishop Tutu's quote and he
says, "Mighty Be Our Powers reminds us that
even in the worst of times, humanity's best
can shine through."
And there's this, as you in your sort of entry
into the, into the book here, the prologue,
you point out that whenever we're looking
at war, you know, we're always seeing the
fighters and we're seeing, you know, these
different leaders arguing and in the background
are often the women and the children and all
the innocent bystanders.
And you somehow figured out how to bring them
right to the front and work together to do
that, which is extraordinary.
But before we get there, I wanted to start
earlier, you know, not that many people are
familiar with Liberia in detail and, and how
you know some of these conflicts started and
what happened and also I love the beginning
of your book because you start it at a peaceful
time.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Yeah.
>>Megan Smith: With your family and your parents,
and who are just sound extraordinary and,
and so could you talk a little bit about that
time?
>>Leymah Gbowee: Well, first, besides being
blown away by Google, Google, I'm happy to
be here.
I'm really honored.
I've been sending text messages to my partner,
who's a tech person, to say you're really
missing, because this is heavenly.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: We grew, I grew up in Liberia
and Liberia is a country that many commentators
of history will tell you the history of Liberia
in itself is conflict.
The history of Liberia starts from 1822 at
the arrival of the free slaves from America.
There is nothing before about the indigenous
people who lived there.
So you hear from the beginning any book you
read, Liberia was founded in 1822.
Indigenous people are not resistant to say,
so what happened to us?
Who welcomed the free slaves?
When the free slaves came to Liberia, and
if you've ever been to any African culture,
you notice that people would get out of their
beds to give the strangers, sort of give you
the best part of the food, the best place
to sleep, so they give them the best land
and everything.
What happened in Liberia was what happened
on the plantation.
Many of those who came had never understood
or knew anything about living peacefully.
So in a short period we had segregated schools,
we had segregated worship places and if you
had a last name like my last name, you could
not go to the university, so they figured
out how to suppress and oppress the indigenous
people.
Liberia gained her independence in 1847.
Indigenous people were not allowed to vote
until 1957.
So if you go back to the history of the black
people here, it Liberia is a mirror image
of everything that happened in the South on
the plantation, it happened to our people
back home.
So for many years people felt cheated, indigenous
people felt cheated.
They were angry.
It built up and built up until the 1980s and
there was a coup.
And then an indigenous soldier became the
president of Liberia.
In support, or to show the power of the indigenous
people, he took 13 of the most powerful descendants
of free slaves and publicly executed them.
So if you go on YouTube you still find images
of the execution of those men.
So whole droves of descendants and relatives
of them moved out of Liberia.
Their properties were seized, it became chaos.
And then in 1989 Taylor started the war.
And the war was funded by free slaves' descendants
in America who felt like we need to revenge
what happened to our people in 1980.
So in Liberia when we the war ended in 2003
and they were talking about TRC, the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission, the conversation
was, where do we start talking about the atrocities?
And they started from 1979.
And people felt like we need to go back to
1822 and start that conversation because that's
where everything started from.
So complicated history, complicated place,
we never really had our own identity as a
people.
Our constitution is modeled after the U.S.
government.
Our flag is like the American flag except
for one star.
Our capital city is named after former President
James Monroe.
We call our money the Liberian dollar, but
it's used simultaneously, side by side with
the U.S. dollar.
If you have the U.S. dollar it's even better
for you.
Everything, we have three branches of government.
So to sum it up, someone who did a documentary
calls Liberia America's step child.
>>Megan Smith: That's very interesting.
[audience chuckles] It's an amazing history
and I think for you personally in the book
you, you basically are talking about some
of this history and then you come to a point
it's really the, your grad, high school graduation
and you have a wonderful story about the community
at that time and your father, your mother,
and I wonder if you could talk a little bit
about them.
And you have three words, community, connection,
confidence.
Big plans.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Growing up we, my parents
are both from indigenous background and they
struggled.
They really had serious struggles with my
dad has a very pathetic childhood story.
His mother gave birth to six children and
every time she gave birth, the child would
die.
And he, when they had him, they were a set
of twin.
His, the other twin died and the community
got together and took him from his mother
and they named her a witch, so she was banished.
She could not play or interact with him.
So he tells stories of growing up in a community,
being taken care of community women and looking
at his mother but never really reaching out
to her because it wasn't allowed.
And later on he was given to live with the
missionaries.
My mother lived with her father, who was a
big agriculturist, agriculturist, he had a
farm.
He was wealthy.
When his wife divorced him, my mother is an
only child.
My father is an only child.
When his wife divorced him he slumped into
depression, she became a child of the community
also.
So both of them tell horror stories of growing
up without their parents, growing up in pains,
and when they got together, I think maybe
that was the connection for their love, I
never really asked them, but she said my dad
was a sweet talker.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: They got together and they
really struggled.
They started having us at, my mother was 17
when she had her first child and then one
after the other we came.
Five girls, no boy.
We, so they tried to really provide us the
kind of family life that they never encountered.
So we lived in a close community.
My mother, my grandmother, who is actually
my grand aunt, well she took care of all of
us and then with different ethnic groups it
was a so-called middle class community at
the time, but it was a poor community if you
comp-, but the richness of that community
was the sense of community, the sense of connection.
You could go to the next neighbor's house,
eat and if it was 7 p.m. as a child, no one
sent you back home dirty.
You took your bath there and they brought
you home.
They would spoil you at that house.
But if you also misbehaved, they would spank
you there.
[audience chuckles] You dare not come back
home and say, "I got spanked" because you
get spanked again.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: So we grew up with that kind
of community.
No one, I never knew that my colleagues had
a different ethnicity, even though they spoke
different languages, but it didn't matter.
It was not until the war came, so I grew up
really in a comfortable, loving environment.
So today my, when I go into any of my childhood
friends' home, those who were Muslims, they
knew exactly what kind of new, when it was
Ramadan we used to cry that we didn't have
new dresses to put on because then my mother
would really find it hard to explain that
we are not Muslims and you can't, for us it
wasn't important, every other child was wearing
something new, so we wore new clothes during
the Ramadan and the Muslim children wore new
clothes during the Christmas, that was the
kind of community we grew up in.
We had street fights.
We, we would fight with the boys.
We would do different things, but if you read
the first part of my book you will see that
it was just a lovely place.
>>Megan Smith: A place we hope all children
can grow.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Can grow up.
And my parents were the kind of people with
all of their problems and if you explain their
marriage within the European/Western context,
people will be sick, so don't even go there,
[people chuckle] because they have their complicated
relationship, but they've managed to stay
together for over 40 years.
So they're still married, they never divorced.
And I think, I, in some way they love each
other, you know?
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: That's an incredible story.
So shortly after the graduation things began,
you were 17 or so.
>>Leymah Gbowee: I went to university.
I was super smart.
I, my, my major was chemistry and minor in
zoology.
I was going to medical school.
I was going to become a pediatrician.
I, it, life was there for the taking and every
day I went to school and then I think it was
we started in March and by July it ended.
We woke up one morning, my mother drove off
to work with my oldest sister, my other sister
had spent the night because we had graduated,
so you could have boyfriends now, so she spent
the night with her boyfriend, but I remember
that I was the only older child of my parents
at home, because I had an afternoon class.
So I was waiting till 2:00.
By 10:00 in the morning, the shooting erupted
and this is where I say that was the moment,
from 8:00 that morning I was a child asking
my mother for cash, by 10:00 I was an adult,
adult taking care of almost 25 people, including
some very young children for a week.
My mother, my father, my siblings never came
back home for almost a week.
When my mother came back she was so traumatized,
she just told me, "Carry on."
And I had, I continue to carry on till today.
>>Megan Smith: Can you tell a little bit about
the, there was a story you told in New York
that I heard you talk about when you guys,
when you left and some of the community, bringing
the community with you and especially the,
the teenage boys and how teenage boys are
treated and what was going on with sort of
that group of.
>>Leymah Gbowee: In 1996, I, I was with my
kids' father and he wasn't the best love.
So for weeks he wasn't around.
And the comm--
>>Megan Smith: At this time you had your older
son, how many children?
>>Leymah Gbowee: I have two and a half.
>>Megan Smith: Ok.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Because I was pregnant.
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: Leymah has six children.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Yes.
>>Megan Smith: The oldest is, is 18 and in
university here in the U.S. and the youngest
is 2, beautiful little girl, we just [inaudible]
>>Leymah Gbowee: So we, we woke up that morning,
but the night before where I live I live in
my parents' house.
I had moved back to my childhood neighborhood.
That's where I was having my children.
And I lived in that house with my uncle, my
aunt.
They had three children and I had my two children,
so we were there and my cousins, group of
boys, and all of their friends live in the
back in a little outhouse.
That, the night before they kept arguing that
oh, there will be no war, there'll be no war,
there'll be no war.
And I kept saying to them, tomorrow there's
definitely going to be war, because there
were too many tensions between the warring
leaders in Monrovia.
The next morning shooting started.
So everyone ran.
People were taking their children and by the
time, by that night somehow, my stray husband
came back and he slept at home.
So when the morning started, the shooting
started, we couldn't decide where we wanted
to go, how, because the bullets were raining
down like thunder on the house, that we started
to see bullets enter the house, so at some
point we decided we have to leave.
So we take the children, run out of the back
door and as we're leaving I see these four
young men from the neighborhood, standing.
And then I say, "I thought you people left
all along."
And they said no, they call me Leymos, so
if you went on the [Liberian word ] and asked
for Leymah you would not get, it's Leymos,
that's my street name.
They said, "Leymos, we were waiting for you
because we didn't know if the children's father
had come and we want to help you to carry
the children."
So they took the two children and we started
walking going.
I was in my nightgown.
We got to a checkpoint and the boy who was
carrying my son was pulled off the line and
then my children's father took my son and
started going.
And I stood up.
Then he said, "Leymah, walk."
And I said, "No.
Because if I leave here, he's going to be
killed."
Because by that time they were interrogating
him.
"We saw you on the airfield.
We saw you and you are a fighter; you were
with the opposing fighting forces" and then
I walked up to them and said, "If you saw
him on the airfield, that's not a lie.
That's where we live."
We said, "Well, we saw him."
He said because, I said, "Where they live
there is no toilet so they go on the open
field to ease themselves and he probably went
there this morning."
So we just had an argument and he was there
really upset, "You want to die, I'm not going
to stay here to die with you."
He walk away, so I stayed there, we argue
it out and they told me "take him".
So the boy and I walked and went to my parents'
house and he stayed at my parents' house for
many years.
But one of the beauty of living with those
young people, fast forward, 2006 these are
boys who cannot afford food to eat and the
reason why we have such close connection is
because every time I made a meal, they had
meal within wait for them in my house.
My sister died in 2006 in Ghana.
I came home with the body and we moved back
because that's where my parents had come back
so we go and come back to that same community
and we were putting when people were coming
every morning women would bring hot water
as for our tradition, because when you're
mourning you can't do anything.
People will come to cook, people will eat,
they will come and sing.
And this day I'm sitting outside, two days
before the funeral.
And those boys come with 1,500 Liberian dollars.
That's a lot of money for those group of people
who cannot even find it to eat.
And they said to me, "Leymos, this is our
contribution to the funeral."
Till I grow old I will never forget.
So when you talk about community, connections.
If I, if you become say President of Liberia,
that community I, I don't live in that community
anymore, but that's the community I register
to vote in.
>>Megan Smith: Nice.
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: Fabulous.
So the world has really fallen apart and one
of the insights that you had, key insights,
was about the mothers.
Interestingly we had a conference recently
at Google with former radical violent extremists
who have transformed their lives and they
are now working for peace and from every continent
and the U.S. and one of the themes that almost
everyone said that at some point, for them,
whether they had been a White Supremacist,
or an Al Qaeda or they were, you know, in
the L.A. gangs or the Rio gangs, somehow their
mother, when they wanted to transform, they
found their mother and they worked with their
mother to come back out and I and so can you
talk about how you got these insights and
how you got there and then what you did?
>>Leymah Gbowee: Well, when we, we, we, the
one thing I tell people is that what I saw
in my mother was what every other mother had
gone through.
Every morning she took her bath and sat out
looking well.
But because I was the older one, I knew how
messed up her mind was.
But she would not cry in public.
When you have a mother who refuses to change
her clothes for almost three months because
for her this represents the death of civility,
in my community that I knew to be a civil
community.
My mother gave a man about five cups of rice.
He walked from this distance to that distance
and he encountered the soldiers.
She standing watching, that for her was the
collapse of her world view of Liberians as
civil people.
And the soldiers asked him, who gave you that?
During the war just a cup of rice was gold
dust.
He looked back and I think his thought was,
if I say her she'll get killed.
He said, "No one."
There, they took a pistol, pop.
I came back from searching for greens and
my mother is wailing, "I killed a man.
I killed a man.
I killed a man."
For years, she never told that story.
She just kept going and added on to our group.
If she saw a child, she's, "Let's take this
one."
So we were five before the war and then we
were almost 20, people from all over.
For she never showed the world her pains.
I had my own pains I was carrying until I
started having my children.
When I started doing the work with the women
I realized that they too had their pains.
But the one thing that was for me a, a rev,
a revealing thing that really made me to step
up the work that I did was, that even in their
pains and their sufferings, these people were
still keeping society going.
>>Megan Smith: Right.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Their communities were still
functioning.
Their children were still eating.
They had some kind, a, a form of strength
that we needed to build on.
A form of energy.
So by the time we started engaging them in
peace work, I didn't have to do anything.
I can't take credit for anything, because
they had ideas.
This is what we should do, this is what we
should do.
They wore me out with their ideas.
So when we started protesting, for me, I appreciate
Pray the Devil Back to Hell, I appreciate
this memoir, I appreciate sitting here at
Google, but I never imagined that what we
did would even be on a screen, let alone me
in this place speaking.
It wasn't for anything, it was our survival
strategy.
It was our survival tactic.
So even till today is almost like a dream
to me coming to all of these places, meeting
all of you people, because I still feel what
I do and the women in Liberia share that,
the women in Congo share that.
What we do in our communities is survival.
So when we came together we had the energy.
We protested.
If you wake up in the morning, you ask an
American, I'm sure all of you have a bank
account, some have insurance, because you
are certain of your tomorrow.
We had come to a place where we were not certain
of a tomorrow.
And when a community get to that place, and
you have children, you start to ask yourself
what future or is there any future for them?
We, as mothers, decided we'll put our broken
bodies out there and protest for peace.
Two years we protested.
Some days we went to protest and it rained
and when it rained that's when you knew who
were wearing the most expensive clothes or
the ones who were wearing the cheap ones,
because the color ran on our legs.
[audience chuckles] The days we didn't have
money to confront some of our warlords, we
walked for hours.
We went to the fighters and we one of the
things till today that those fighters who
always say, you are people of your word.
And that's the difference between women, peace
builders, negotiators, because even if it
would kill them, they would stick to their
word.
And so when we started engaging the fighters,
especially when disarmament failed in December,
this, they were telling each other, you can
count on them.
If they say they are coming back tomorrow,
they will come back.
So if we woke up the next morning and we had
promised a group of fighters that we were
coming and we didn't have money for transportation,
we walked.
But it, like you rightly said, all of those
men, all of those violent offenders, they
looked back, two things flashed past their
minds.
Even when we're destroying, these are the
people holding us up.
Even the gang members after they go out and
do everything they come home, their mothers
are there.
And they are the pillar of strength.
That's the first thing.
The second thing if I decide to go through
a process of transformation, if no one believes
that what I'm doing is true or sincere, this
mother will believe me and she's always there
to give me a second chance, so those are the
things that probably make them come back to
us and come back to us and come back to us.
>>Megan Smith: You had that wonderful expression
that your mom used about I'll tie my middle,
can you say a little bit about that and what
she said?
>>Leymah Gbowee: My, my life had taken a dip
like many of us and I is nothing that you
can compare to anyone.
I was at a place where every time I shook,
a baby dropped.
It was just terrible and then I was in this
abusive relationship that I had finally gained,
gotten the courage to step out of, but I slept
all day, I became a bum.
That's how you call it here, right?
[audience chuckles] Sleeping, not wanting
to do anything.
So I was a bum.
>>Megan Smith: That's depressed.
>>Leymah Gbowee: On my parents' couch.
And then this night we were sweeping and she
said, she had my third child on her back and
I was pregnant with my fourth.
My dad would call me a baby machine that he
was disappointed in me and he was really disappointed
because of all of his children I think because
he knew how smart I was, he felt like I was
going places.
So when my life just deteriorated to having
children and staying in an abusive relationship,
he was very bitter and he made some very horrible
comments at me.
I forgive him now because there is nothing
else I can do, he's dependent on me.
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: Goes back around full circle?
>>Leymah Gbowee: Well he's old, so I have
to take care of him, that's what I've been
taught to do.
And I don't hold anything against him because
by in hindsight having my own children now,
I would do the same thing, maybe even worse.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: But this night we're standing
out and we've swept the grass and put it in
a drum and it's like a bonfire and my mother
asked me, "What do you want to do with your
life?"
And she said, "Leymah."
I say, "Yes, ma'am."
She say, "If you decide to do anything positive
with your life, I promise you this night I
will tie my waist and stand by you.
If you want to go to school, I will take care
of these children.
If you want to work, I will take care of these
children."
In essence, she was saying to me, I will be
your pillar of strength.
Till today as I'm here if I pick the phone
and say to my mom, "Go to the U.S. Embassy,
they will give you your visa, I need you in
San Francisco" she drops everything and comes.
It's not, my dad says, "Leymah has a way of
confusing us.
[audience laughs] She'll pick the phone and
say come, come oh, come, you have to come
so Grandma I need you, I need you, I need
you.
Without thinking we are on the next flight
to her."
What's so, and so I mean you can't but forgive
anyone who has been very negative to you but
continue to be supportive.
You get to the place where you understand,
so my mother has been that way, I will tie,
so if I have a challenging task ahead of me,
as a matter of fact I call her every day,
regardless of which part of the world I find
myself, I'll call her.
And then I say, "Pea", I call her Pea.
"I am, I need you to pray for me."
And she said, "That has been taken care of
this morning.
[audience laughs] Anything else?"
But we just chat and we just talk.
Because I see that woman as a pillar of strength
and I keep saying to myself and to my kids
that I am that pillar of strength so tell
me anything even if it is the most painful
thing in this world, I want to be that supportive
mother.
I want to be your friend.
I want to be your partner in any venture.
I want to be there, I want to be, I want to
be, I want to be.
And I think we are on that road to the point
that my 13-year old came to tell me a few
months ago she fall in love.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: And then I went, "Jesus,
Jesus, Jesus, give me the strength not to
box this child."
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: So I said, "Well, let me
think about it", and then I came back to her
and said, "The love you found has earned you
an all-girls boarding school.
[audience laughs] And they're going to cut
your hair."
A few weeks later she said, "Momma, you know
I don't think that love is worth it.
I've let him go.
I will do it some other time."
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: Excellent.
Fabulous.
So we had Gloria Steinem on stage yesterday
we had our Fortune conference and she's an
amazing leader for women around the world
and in our country and she was quoting Alice
Walker the author saying the main way we lose
power is to think we don't have any.
And what you leading and the women did was
came together first as we saw in some of the
depictions in the film with the white dress
and standing bearing witness and then later
as you with the sex strike and getting Charles
Taylor to come to the peace talks.
Can you tell the story about when you went
to the peace talks and they were not getting
it done, what you guys did?
>>Leymah Gbowee: We went to the peace talks
first real All of the work we did we were
naīve.
We didn't think that, we didn't think through
nonviolent struggle, we didn't think through
the movement, we didn't think about the costly
nature.
We went to Accra with $1,000 thinking it would
last us two weeks and we would be back home
with a peace agreement.
It lasted three months.
And in three months a ceasefire had failed.
In three months, we observed our warlords
end the peace talks and sit by the pool of
their hotel and get massaged by girls in bikinis,
meanwhile you listen to the radio, 200 people
had died.
A missile landed here.
And then they were just disrespectful to us
sitting there protesting.
Every morning they passed they would insult
us.
Some of them called us Taylor's girlfriends,
depending on how they felt that morning.
Some of them called us, so we, we had gotten
to that place, I had gotten to the place where
I had lost every confidence I had ever had
in nonviolence, because I got to the place
where I started questioning myself.
What good is sitting here?
The ones who are committing the evil, they're
being protected, they're being paid.
We can't even find food.
We were 10 to a hotel room.
We didn't have anything and these people were
coming with siren cars, bodyguards.
So I started until it reached to a point where
I stopped going to protest.
The women would go to protest and I would
just call and I would not be home, I would
just wander, I would just walk and walk and
I was crying so badly there that I developed
an eye infection.
I just cried and I was very angry.
This day I was watching the Associated Press
video from Liberia on Yahoo.
And they showed two little boys who had woken
up that morning to brush their teeth.
A missile landed.
All that left of those two boys were their
slippers.
They were crushed.
A girl had given birth the night before, she
came to hang her baby's diapers.
She was also crushed.
On that video her mother had the young baby
showing to the press people, say she give
birth less than four hours ago, what do I
do with this child?
I got up, put on my white t-shirt, went to
the peace hall and said to Shugas, "Do you
have money?"
Shugas is my mentor.
She said, "Leymah, I have a little bit."
I say, "Let's send for more women from the
refugee camp."
She say, "Why?"
I say, "I'll let you know, just send for the
women."
She called and told the women, the women were
always ready.
They just got into a bus and they made the
journey.
The journalists were about to leave and I
went to them and said, "Don't go.
You have a story to write today."
And they said, "Miss Gbowee, what?"
"Just stay for a few hours."
Ten o'clock, the warlords went into the peace
hall.
As soon as they went in, I went to the women,
there were about maybe 100 close to 200, sit
at the door and loop arms.
And they just followed.
They went and sat and looped arms so we barricaded
the entrance of the hall and then I went in
and sat down and wrote my hostage note just
like in the movies,
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: except I didn't have the
sound thing.
Then I tapped on the glass door of the peace
hall and a Nigerian general, who is late now,
turned and look at me and I said to you, he
said me, he said, I said please come.
He came, I handed him the note, I said for
the chief negotiator.
He took it to him.
He read it and on the overhead speaker he
said, "Oh my God.
Distinguished ladies and gentlemen, General
Leymah and her troops have seized the peace
hall."
Commotion in the room.
So he came outside.
But when they sound, when he made that announcement
the police came running.
And then they said they would arrest me.
Why?
For obstructing justice.
I spoke about my childhood.
I spoke earlier about that place I grew up
in the belief in the protection of women and
children.
That moment flashed past me.
And I realized that this is a dog eat dog's
world.
No one will fight for you.
No one will protect you.
Everything that had been socialized to believe,
all of my value system collapsed at that moment.
Me, obstructing justice, when all I'm trying
to do for months all I've been trying to do
with these women is to bring a semblance of
justice into their lives.
I said, "Sir."
He said, "Yes?"
"I'll make it very easy for you to, to arrest
me."
I took off my head tie and he said, "What
are you doing?"
I say, "I'm stripping naked for you."
When I was taking off my wrap, this Liberian
man came and grabbed me and said, "Don't do
that."
But as he grabbed me, all of the security
men have fled, those who were arresting me,
because they didn't want to be in the face
of bad luck.
The men who were arresting me came back to
say, "Send your women to the windows because
the delegates are jumping out of the windows."
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: So we had to send women to
the window to seize that side of the window.
But after that act, we went in the room, they
negotiated with us and there was the feeling
of emancipation.
We had been begging for peace and now they
were negotiating with us.
Oh man.
That was a good feeling.
So we came back and said yes, we would let
them out of there, but these are our conditions.
That peace hall that had been a place that
was like a circus turned sober and in three
weeks we had a peace agreement signed.
>>Megan Smith: Amazing.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Yeah.
>>Megan Smith: Just incredible.
That's leadership.
So the war ended and things transitioned and
so I'd love to cut to-- before we open up
to questions, to what you are doing now.
I mean 75 percent of the Liberian infrastructure
was destroyed.
And so the election.
>>Leymah Gbowee: We got African first female
president.
>>Megan Smith: Yes.
>>Leymah Gbowee: And we're fighting to reelect
her again.
Now my work, I've taken it out of Liberia
and into the region.
I run an organization called Women Peace and
Security Network Africa.
One of the things we came to understand after
we did all we did in Liberia was that there's
no way you can talk about peace without the
whole issue of security.
And there's no way you can talk about a conventional
form of security without looking at the human
security aspect.
So after wars, one of the most exotic things
you see in the world now is that countries
go into this post-conflict countries and say,
"We want to reconstruct or reform your army."
And they put billions of dollars into those
processes and then where you have the army
barracks being built, the communities are
living in shanty towns.
So the conversation then that we've started
is beyond the military infrastructure, can
there be a balance between basic social services
and military infrastructure?
Because if you buy all of the jet bombers
of the world and people needs are not met,
these are the same people who will come and
attack your jet bombers and conflict will
erupt.
So we've started that conversation.
Beyond that we recognize that our work, my
12, my 13-year old at 12 told me once, "Momma,
your work is all about you and your friends
talking to each other."
We've never really included women in the private
sector, women in the military.
So now we're going back to military institutions,
security institutions to ask them, how are
you doing your work?
[coughing] Excuse me.
How are you doing your work that women are
not saying in the leadership, so for example,
in West Africa, Sierra Leone has the only
woman brigadier general in all of the armies
in West Africa.
So we are asking these people, how are you
doing your work?
And then we're asking the women, how are you
surviving?
And how are we outside, how can we help you
do your work easier?
So how can we connect rural women with military
women, young girls with military women?
So that there is not this misconception about
security, that security is out there and community
is down here and security is there to trample
on community.
We want to start a whole new conversation
about how security is negotiated.
The second part of our work is leaders.
We do leadership for girls.
But I was telling you earlier on that we got
a whole $100,000 worth, I spoke at Tina Brown's
event in New York about a year ago and the,
one of the heads of HP was there and he decided
we will give you whatever you want, so they
give us $100,000 worth of equipment shipped
from here to Liberia.
I was excited when we got it because one of
the trainings we held for the women in the
security sector, there were 50 of the most
senior, none of them knew how to send bulk
text messages.
Of all of the women in that room, only two
had e-mail addresses.
And the two that had addresses, children were
the ones who did their e-mails for them.
So we felt like this thing from HP would be
a good thing to set up an IT center that will
call for leadership in excellence where women,
girls can come to learn.
So that's our newest project.
We launched the center.
Sorry.
I've seen this happen to white people, not
me.
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: One thing I'll tell you while
you, you collect your voice.
We were able to do internet camp in Monrovia
>>Leymah Gbowee: Ok.
>>Megan Smith: about two years ago and so
I'm excited to hear that the center is there
because we met extraordinarily talented techies,
our colleagues, our Google kindred spirits
there and so we will make sure that we interconnect
them and bring them.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Definitely because I have
no idea, my work is protest, my work is women's
issue, I took out my iPad because I was at
Google and I wanted to feel like I'm part
of you folks.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: But since I bought it, I
don't know the futures.
I play Scrabble and check my mails.
That's it.
I didn't buy it, I got it as a Christmas present.
So we do, the IT center is set up and right
now we're at a place where we want, we're
my partner is an IT person and he is our consultant
because I have no idea so he helped me through
the whole negotiation with HP.
So we're now having a conversation on how
we want to run that place beyond setting up
e-mails and all of the different things, my
take is that we will go into the public schools
and get girls, train them on the weekends
so that when they're leaving high school in
September of next year, each of them have
a basic knowledge of using the computer.
That's how I see it.
We're also bringing women from the Sierra
Leone army to pair them with the Liberian
army to train them at that center.
How is going to be done, I don't know.
All I know is that the Norwegian government
has given us $8,000 to bring these women from
Sierra Leone to Liberia.
What will be the content of the training,
please don't ask me.
So we do that whenever we have something called
Girls in Leadership Project.
We work with girls in the community.
We have something called the West African
Women Policy Forum that we partner with another
group.
Every year we bring a think tank of women
from civil society government and the regional
economic community so that we share our experiences
around women's political participation.
As I speak, this year, as part of our convening
for five, for the last five years we've organized
the first ever West African women elections
observance mission.
>>Megan Smith: Fabulous.
>>Leymah Gbowee: So those women we are now
in Liberia to observe the elections, but what
they're observing is not the conventional
thing.
So they're observing how women are treated
during the polls, you know, pregnant women,
if they were given preference and all of those
different things that just to see how our
election is conducted in Africa that either
turn women off from going to the polls or
encourage women to go to the polls.
The final thing we do now, we have something
called Youth Security and Development with
the minister of youth and sports . And they
allow the Youth Security and Development Project
we are looking at youth justice and accountability.
The problem with West Africa now is the youth
bulge, no jobs.
Violence is their first take.
So we want to really start talking, working
with these young people, start having conversations
with them to really see where can we take
it from here to there.
And I would really, really love to see you
know I know that Google has been back and
forth to Liberia, what has come out of it
I don't know because I don't even have a Twitter
or Facebook account, so this is just to see.
I don't have a Gmail, I'm so embarrassed.
[laughter]
>>Megan Smith: We'll get you one.
>>Leymah Gbowee: And so, but just to think
about the youth, think about technology, think
about where the world is and what kind of
assistance not just for Liberia but for other
countries that are emerging out of conflict.
Because where the world is now if this young
people might get, must get jobs.
They have to be able to do some of the things
that the little children in this country can
do.
So basically that's the work that I do.
Beyond that, I get invited to places like
here to shoot my mouth off, [audience chuckles]
to talk about how the international community
is failing miserably in building peace and
yet last night someone asked me a question
at a panel I was in Seattle.
And I said to the lady, please in two weeks
I have to apply for my visa, don't let them
blacklist me for a new visa because I have
my own opinion about the politics of this
nation, but I do a lot and I feel like I'm
grounded because I go into the communities
and work.
At the national level I'm able to sit with
policy makers and say this other policy is
not working.
This is working.
And I'm able to go at the international level
and talk to people about some of the needs
in these communities.
One of the examples of our work with the girls,
in one community, in three years not a single
girl has graduated from high school.
This year is the first time they have five
girls that are about to graduate from high
school in that community.
So the President of Liberia had no idea, so
working at community we're able to come back
to them to say these are some of the problems
we've seen.
But also the people you have in control of
that particular community you need to fire
them because they are not doing the right
thing.
So we're able to do that kind of so I feel
like I'm at a privileged place, a blessed
place, you know, where I'm able to go back
and forth at different levels and do what
I love doing.
Beyond that as much as I like to come outside
I, I feel the best part of my work is in a
community because that what keeps me grounded,
reminds me every day of the reason for the
struggle in the first place.
Yeah.
>>Megan Smith: Fabulous.
We love to help you with the tech center.
We have seen amazing groups all around the
world who created curriculum.
One of my favorite ones, there's some here,
in Silicon Valley and other places, but one
of them is a group called Mirabits, that's
been going for a dozen years now, taking very
talented youth leaders out of the slums in
Kibera in Nairobi, training them on internet
how to you know HTML and, and really making
web pages, blogging, etc. and then come right
into the tech center in Nairobi, so going
from no job possibility to right in, so there's
programs like that that we can connect the
talent in Liberia to.
I want to open up quick to questions and so
you have a little bit more time
or if you just have a comment.
Yeah.
>>female #3: Hi.
As I watched Pray the Devil Back to Hell several
months ago and I found it very stunning visually,
just to see the all white that you were sitting
in and the linking of the arms and blocking
the men from coming into the buildings and
you know them having to walk around you and
what I felt was when you'd, you'd mentioned
the quote by Alice Walker about power and
you know the only time you don't have power
is when you don't think you have it or whatever
and what I really felt when I was watching
it is like if you looked at a superficial
level it just looked like there's no way they're
gonna be safe even let alone be you know have
these men trying to negotiate with you.
And I just wondered, I know you've said you
did this for pure survival, and I just wondered
if you had any sense while you were in it
of how powerful you were before the tides
turned and they asked you to negotiate and
also if you just had moments of sheer terror
or kind of what you were running on and were
there moments of joy and?
>>Leymah Gbowee: You know I always get this
question, were you afraid?
The war started when I was 17.
I had my moments with terror in those early
stages.
The first time I saw a dead body I froze.
By the time I was 31, I could walk over a
dead body without a second thought.
So fear had become, I had become immune to
anything called fear.
That was the first thing.
The second thing what I felt powerful.
When we started the protests there were little
things that made me gradually over time recognize
that people feared us.
Small things that would happen.
We went to Parliament and the speaker of Parliament
and I got into a confrontation and we came
this close to having a fistfight.
The women came between us.
No one arrested me.
I checked that.
The following time we were seated on the airfield
he came and said president, he sent his bodyguard
to call me that he had a message from the
President.
And I told the bodyguard, "Go and tell your
boss I'm in my office, he should come and
see me."
He got out of his car, walked to me, check
that.
We went to Accra and the warlords from the
other warring faction had come and the women
went to meet him and they knelt down and I
saw a total change in his expression and then
he became insulting.
I told them, "Get up, get up, get up."
And then I looked him straight in the eye
and told him, "You fool, you will never get
us to kneel down before you again."
Whenever we have to talk to you we'll talk
to you at this level.
And then he say, "You will get nothing from
me."
I said, "Let's see."
We went back to a meeting and we decided as
women, no more we kneel before any man to
appeal for peace.
So gradually we learned those lessons and
gradually we knew that people feared us.
And gradually our confidence in what we did
grew and our confidence in ourselves grew.
My dear, someone says that injection that
the women took, we wish we had a way to undo
it because it's too much for the Liberian
people now.
[audience chuckles]
>>Megan Smith: Other questions?
[pause]
>>female #4: Hi.
So my question is that I noticed that in the
press especially here in America what really
got covered was the fact that the women were
withholding sex from the men and if you watch
the documentary and the book it doesn't really
play that big of a role and so I'm wondering
how you, how you felt about that.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Well, you know this country,
the sex industry keeps the financial wheel
turning.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: If I could put it that way.
And I'm on YouTube, oh my God.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: I'll tell you a story.
My sister lives in New York and we have our
girl time when I'm there.
So we're flipping through the pages of a magazine
and imagining that we are big shots now and
the advert, there's an advert in this magazine
of a watch, a wristwatch and there is this
young man in his underwear with the wristwatch
on his thigh.
And then I said, "Fata, which part of his
body is going to wear this watch?"
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: She said, "I don't know."
I say, "Is there a new way of wearing watch
in America?"
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: "Because I don't see the
correlation of a young man with everything
showing and a watch on his thigh.
Please tell me that there is not a new way
of wearing watch in this country."
[audience chuckles] And that image is what
people will go with, some will wear a silver
watch to that other side.
But that was what it implied.
So anything about sex will sell.
So people will ask questions and sometimes
I think one of the reasons why they were they
asked a lot of questions about the sex strike
is not because sex also sell or because the
thing is you are the, the image of African
women is that we're weak and we're battered
most of the time and we have no control over
our bodies.
So how can you be withholding sex when you
are the slaves of your men?
So it's like, hmm, let's assume really, you
know?
But the image is not always what it seem.
And yes we did start that strategy, it didn't
last in the urban areas very long for many
reasons.
But in the rural areas the women were more
strategic.
They invited their husbands to the church
and said we're on a journey to peace building
and this journey is going to entail fasting,
praying and different actions.
And you know the act of fasting is the act
of denial of the, the, the pleasures of food,
sex and all of these things.
So we are appealing to you that as we fast,
we cannot engage and those men were the ones
who were being killed on a daily basis.
They wanted peace also.
So they agreed.
And for months they did not have sex, these
women were not having sex.
They didn't go with "we are on a strike",
but they were on a strike.
The day we ended the protest two years later
in one of the communities because we went
all around the country to launch the protest
and we went all around the country to end
the protest.
So when we ended in one of the communities
we were about to end the program and a woman
came to me and said, no and there is a final
presentation we'll see these old men, chiefs,
rural men coming with flowers, some of them
had gifts wrapped and they were calling their
wives one at a time and telling them thank
you for bringing peace and one of them leaned
over to me and says, "It's all about the sex
tonight."
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: Because the gift was like
you know the fast is finished, the war is
over, now we can do something today.
[laughter] But yes.
But also I mean just to come back as someone
working with young people, the, the use of
the media and that overt objectification is
destroying not just this country, but our
country as well.
Young girls now think their bodies starts
from here, starts from here, end here.
It's not there, it's not there.
When I was growing up we made candies to sell.
If you look at the pictures in this book you
will see me selling donut as a refugee in
Ghana.
Today not many refugee girls are interested
in selling donuts.
Why do I want to sell donut when I will make
$2 and if I sell myself I can make $20.
So that, the whole, the, the, I think you
people need to start a campaign here, showcasing
the very smart women that the world of Google
is not turning on here and here, it's turning
on their brains.
All of those girls who are going on Facebook
and Twitter and YouTube to expose themselves,
I think you need to put out on YouTube the
young women who keep this place turning so
that people understand that our world has
not degenerated to our sexual organs.
My, I have my white nieces they go to universities
because since I've been coming to America,
I have many white relatives, so if you bring
your children who will start calling me aunties
and they will become my left auntie and then
they are my nephews if you bring yours.
Gloria Steinem was in Accra, she spent some
days at the house and the children will go
Auntie Gloria, Auntie Gloria, Auntie Gloria
and then my son said, "Wow, we have even white
aunties."
That's your wahalla as the Nigerians would
say.
But one of my white nieces tell the story
or I'm told the story about her campus of
how the only thing they do there is hooking
up.
[pause] So I said, "So what is hooking up?"
"So Miss Leymah, you hook up, you hook up."
So hooking up is sex.
They don't have relationships like boyfriend
and girlfriend anymore where they sit and
talk and get to know each other, so I see
you, I like you, we hook up and you like me,
we hook up.
And in order to be in you have to hook up.
Oh my God.
[Megan murmurs in response] So I think there
is a road as part of your corporate social
responsibility not just to America but to
the world.
You have the technology.
Can I kindly shoot myself in the foot again,
open my big mouth to say, can you do a YouTube
video profiling the young people, young women
specifically who work in this decent institution,
let them talk about their, you have all these
scientists and techy girls and, and they are
not ugly, see you, you can pass for a beauty
queen.
[audience laughs] You, you can be Miss India.
I mean you are beautiful people and even the
young men here.
I haven't seen anyone with their sagging pants.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: Even if your pants are sagging,
we will not be looking at that other part,
we will look at your brain because you, too,
are doing something to keep the wheels of
this place functioning.
The world is upside down.
>>Megan Smith: You are here in Silicon Valley
in the heart of entrepreneurship where people
are driven by passion to make the world better
to be entrepreneurs, to do great things in
science and math together with the arts are
really are--
>>Leymah Gbowee: You need to take it out of
Silicon Valley because I, I'm telling you
in the other valleys it's all about sex.
[laughter]
>>Leymah Gbowee: It is really very serious.
When a 13-year old come to her mother and
say, "I found a boy and I fell in love."
Oh my God.
Another friend told me her 13-year old was
asking her to buy her thongs.
[pause]
>>female #5: Thongs.
>>female #6: What?
>>Leymah Gbowee: Thongs.
You know that thing?
>>female #6: Yeah.
>>Megan Smith: You know the interesting thing
that Geena, Geena Davis, the actress who was
in Thelma and Louise and won, academy award
winning actress, has done some research about
media for very, very young children and her
discovery with some work with USC Annenberg
Center is that in the film and television
that's made for zero to six year olds in the
U.S. and which is exported in many places,
it's amazing to look at the statistics maybe
on screen it's three to one boys to girls
and the jobs that are held by the characters,
80 percent of the jobs held, for if your,
your child is watching TV in these shows are
held by men and the 20 percent that are held
by women characters are you know there's no
lawyers, there's no scientists, there's no
businesswomen.
You know you take a wonderful movie like Nemo,
Finding Nemo, how many girls in the ocean?
One.
That's just not true.
And so by the time you're three you're learning
this in fact to the point of sexuality is
that when you only have one character, girl
character on screen, they sexualize her.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Um hmm.
>>Megan Smith: And so you can go to the Smurfs
and you see all these different kinds of boys
including the nerdy boy or nerdy, you know,
girl who was a girl who would work at Google
and, and build these tech careers, but the
one girl is the Barbie girl, you know and
so sexification of, of young children, pulling
them into that I think there's a lot of, your
point is very well taken about telling these
stories better in the media.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Please do, please because
if you don't I will do my own YouTube video
and say YouTube why are you not doing this?
Because this is something that we could do.
This is so, this is so, let me conclude with
my advocacy.
>>Megan Smith: We would love that.
Great.
>>Leymah Gbowee: Let Google not only should
you show kids, young women with brains here
to inspire other young women.
Tell them that I got this job based on merit.
>>Megan Smith: Right.
>>Leymah Gbowee: And not sex.
I am where I am based on my brains and not
my body even though the b spells the same
thing.
And then reach out to other communities.
Can you girls in this place start your own
revolution beyond Silicon Valley and start
showcasing yourself.
Someone asked me if you met Beyonce what would
you do, would you ask her for an autograph?
I said no, I will ask her to come and join
me in my campaign because I want her to sit
and tell young girls beyond their booty shake,
I have a brain.
[someone's cellphone rings] Because they don't
understand that part.
And I would want, if I ever met Jay-Z, I would
want to tell him to tell young boys beyond
the yo, yo, yo, I have a brain, that's why
I am a business genius.
>>Megan Smith: There's this side of it, yeah.
Very much.
>>Leymah Gbowee: So I think there's so much
that we all can do to make this world a better
place.
My story is from a tiny part of the world.
Your story is from this gigantic place and
you can use your space to do good.
Google, join me.
Let's change our world.
Thank you all for coming to this interview.
>>Megan Smith: Leymah Gbowee
[applause]